everyone has a different way of coping
with the chaotic soul-destroying
nightmare that is soloqueue for some the
goal is to become that nightmare for
others it's to succeed in spite of it
guys guys please please you're both
wrong whether it's leavers cheaters team
killers loudmouth Silver's or people who
use the m4a1-s over the m4a4 we've all
been burned by the inextinguishable
hellfire that is online matchmaking the
question is how you deal with it because
how you act in soloqueue actually says a
lot about who you are as a player but
for one of the sweetest most selfless
and most strategic legends in the
history of Counter Strike the answer was
simple become someone else entirely
someone bad meat bad fallen
he's the alter ego Gabriel fallen Toledo
uses to combat the idiocy zuv ranked bad
fallen is mean
[Music]
he's manipulative guys give me a weapon
please thank you
heart yeah thank you it's better and
weirdly enough he provides exactly the
kind of ruthless candid direction that
the vast majority of players are in
desperate need of help ourself I suppose
safer for hard winter gear for supreme
arrow internal guard bestow [ __ ] people
more deals Cara
bula-bula tidal pool of elephants a
second silk Agora so how is it that a
slimy stream central persona became both
a source for educational content and one
of the most beloved figures in all of
counter-strike
[Music]
okay so if you're a fan of eSports and
you're not familiar with fallen well you
should be he's one of the most
thunderous offers to ever live as they
both get close enough rain considering
up or has a look even waiting for the
push in fallen gets the spray shot
anyway very positive waiting gambling
that both players come from the same
side and he is correct in that
assumption nothing he three but on top
of being a two-time major winner fallin
has dedicated himself to God fathering
the Brazilian scene whether it's through
classes he offers at his version of
counter-strike University or his ability
to discover raw talent and polish it
into superstardom now in addition to
being one of the most important
counter-strike players of all time
fallen is pretty much a poster boy for
positivity the dude is indescribably
humble service offering no IDs top
earning mighty men and a literal hero to
an entire generation of CS fans a very
good job but just say Joe did a good job
back up my strength
good job so how did we get from bad now
it isn't exactly clear how or when bad
fallen was born what is clear is why for
a goody-two-shoes like regular fallen
bad fallen was a way to cheekily
confront the chaotic nightmare that has
ranked matchmaking bet falling is a joke
it came up when I was like really
needing to say stuff that I couldn't say
myself and then just started me
something funny you see of all the awful
ranked cultures and eSports CS goes
might just be the worst
can you guys shut up on we're playing
man quit like you suck you're a manlet
and you're an economy size car human and
I'm a full-size truck evolved alpha male
at the professional level the game is a
beautiful structured Symphony a battle
of skill and strategy between maestro's
but at the casual level it is a cesspool
of toxic teenagers the racist 30 year
olds they're screaming at and just to
see of staticy ass bomb reps see that's
the problem with matchmaking it's
capable of driving even the most
big-brained players to the brink of
despair and it doesn't matter how
earnestly you try to help your teammates
sooner or later they will [ __ ] the bed
so fallen came up with a solution adopt
a silly satirical streamer persona that
could combat the shortcomings of his
smooth brained compatriots
[Music]
flesh again ready known for his
signature shades and super cringy
jawline bad fallens interests included
stomping on scrubs
look at that flashes dishing out bad
mannered beatdowns
wait wait wait wait another wait wait
wait wait wait wait
and pretending to be a racecar whereas
regular fallen was structured systematic
and selfless bad fallen was anything but
he was pretty much the physical
embodiment of soloqueue when I played
the glasses if they ask hey can you
boost me no you boost me yeah yeah
that's what it is you boost me you write
a lot of thinking that wish you could I
see bit of you [ __ ] I statistically
boost but I used to be real no please
help [ __ ]
who's the widow whose meet with me oh
yeah and if you did something wrong you
could be damn sure that he'd call you
out on it you [ __ ] face a quarter
bazooka you know Facebook bestow my
colleague a CTO like I'd assume Cooper
Sica reverse reddish alcoholic it cost
us people loved bad fallen and from a
learning perspective they found it
weirdly helpful to have him quarterback
their every move
safe about a fella
nice rod spaceman nice your argument it
got to the point where subscribers
started sending in clips for bad fallen
to have a go at and man was this dude a
savage para eco let you do Kenny a snap
on the people don't lick me
my mother put my monopod so got a bikini
s Corrado secured okay yes so I'm a poor
shaky Secret of fátima magico Cinco
Mariner quarter boys shooting a quote
hysterical kokuto can ya see much food I
replied that fallen might have started
as a small inside joke but over time he
began to gain some serious traction and
eventually even the server's couldn't
contain him anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
people have been talking a lot about
this matchup that's coming by the hotel
something it's gonna be easy I will give
you some reasons why you're gonna lose
face first your coach is old what to say
about a walk right off was the best
player in the world 2015 because I
wasn't playing yet I was doing some
other stuff but when I came in Orlov
never showed up again where I didn't I
saw you watching at practice yesterday
and we were trying to learn something
but it's just too much just too much for
you fast forward to today and bad fallen
remains one of the most beloved
community-wide memes in all of
counter-strike
inspiring both adoration and imitation
we came up with something called bed
taco and I mean take it too far
the question is why and the answer is
pretty simple it's because on some level
we are all Batphone it's pretty easy to
be bad Alex oh can I be bad Alex yeah
okay I thought Alex was already bad now
you can be yourself [ __ ] you look
Counter Strike is a mesmerizing
masterfully crafted eSport but there are
plenty of times where it makes all of us
lose our goddamn minds the key is to
temper that rage control it and deal
with it in a healthier way as weird as
it may sound bad fallen is actually a
force for good he's helped
counter-strike players the world over
confront their anger issues and stands
as a constant reminder that come what
may the only person in control of your
fate on the server is you not even surf
man falling himself can turn this around
only a USP got no kit is he gonna do it
I think he will
[Applause]
falling thirty-year-olds they're
screaming at an a-c of stab icky ass
bong rips that might be the best line
I've ever written for this series I know
I'm gonna be honest man that might be
the best line that I've ever written for
the series it's like and nothing is more
like truthful in that line but that line
is the truth that line is literally like
biblical oh drop my phone oh good good
and stands as a constant reminder why do
they always edit my last line to be so
[ __ ] long